a few years ago bitcoin skyrocketed
as fomo kicked in which pushed bitcoin
up to 20
000 per coin however as the bitcoin
bubble popped
we saw an 80 pullback with the bitcoin
bottoming out and four thousand dollars
but
since then bitcoin has started a whole
another bull run
standing upwards of fourteen thousand
dollars per coin
today so will bitcoin be able to break
through its old high and transition
into a viable currency or is another
crash
inevitable
[Music]
well starting off let's take a look at
how bitcoin
even works bitcoin has four main sectors
with the first being bitcoin wallets to
access bitcoin
the traditional way is to open a bitcoin
wallet which can be done on your
computer
or smartphone creating this wallet will
give you
your first bitcoin address and this is
what you will need to use to complete
transactions
your bitcoin address is basically the
same thing
as your phone number or email address
and
is what friends family or customers will
use to send you money
one major difference however is that
each bitcoin address is only intended to
be used once
unlike traditional phone numbers and
email addresses
next up we have the blockchain the
blockchain
is basically the brain of bitcoin and
many other cryptocurrencies
as well the blockchain keeps track of
all of the transactions that have taken
place
regarding the given cryptocurrency in
chronological order
this database of transactions is what
allows bitcoin wallets to keep track of
the remaining balance
of each user moving on we have private
keys
private keys or the encryption security
aspect when it comes to many
cryptocurrencies
each bitcoin wallet is assigned a secret
private key
and this private key is used to ensure
the authenticity
of each transaction the private key also
prevents completed transactions
from being modified by anyone and
finally
we have the most glamorized part of
cryptocurrency which is of course
mining mining is when an individual
embarks on trying to add undiscovered
cryptocurrency onto the blockchain
to accomplish this one must solve
insanely difficult computational puzzles
which may result in the addition of new
bitcoins
and as we all know computing these
puzzles
are extremely difficult leading to
massive amounts of computational power
being required
to discover new bitcoin now one thing to
note
is that miners cannot indefinitely
continue
mining new bitcoin as there is a limit
of 21 million bitcoins
so they're not really adding new bitcoin
to the database
per se rather they're making
undiscovered bitcoin
available for use in essence bitcoin
wallets provide
access to bitcoin the blockchain keeps
track of transactions
and balances private keys legitimize
transactions
and prevent modification and mining
increases the bitcoin
that is available to trade with all that
being said
let's take a look at the factors
influencing the recent rise of bitcoin
starting with inflation as we all know
we are currently
undergoing an economic recovery meaning
that the federal reserve has decreased
interest rates in an attempt to
stimulate economic activity
on top of this the federal reserve has
also been printing trillions of dollars
over the last several months in fact the
federal reserve printed more money in
one month
than through two centuries currently the
general consensus
amongst economists is that our biggest
concern right now
is still deflation and that we won't
really be dealing with any inflation
for a few more years despite this
printing so much money
isn't the most assuring and this has
influenced many investors to put aside
some of their money
in cryptocurrency as cryptocurrency
cannot inflate
as i mentioned earlier there's only a
limited supply of bitcoin
which stands at a total of 21 million
coins
out of that 21 million 18.5 million
bitcoins
have already been mined meaning that
only two and a half million coins
are outstanding once these coins have
been mined
the total supply of bitcoin will
stabilize bitcoin's protocol
can be changed to allow for a larger
supply of bitcoin
however considering that the currency
was invented to protect against
inflation
this is unlikely along with protecting
against inflation bitcoin can even be
argued to be a deflationary currency
as it becomes progressively harder to
mine for bitcoin
the difficulty of bitcoin mining is
controlled by what is known
as the happening the happening describes
a moment
in which bitcoin's block subsidy is
halved bitcoin's block subsidy
is simply the amount of bitcoin that a
miner receives for successfully
mining a full block and every 210
000 blocks or roughly every four years
the reward for mining a block
is cut in half we are already in the
tail end of bitcoin mining
as upwards of 90 of the supply has
already been mined
however as mining simply gets
exponentially harder
as we move forward it is expected that
mining will continue
all the way up to 2140 but at that point
the slight increase in available supply
due to mining
is unlikely to really impact the value
of each bitcoin
considering the limited supply and
increasing difficulty
of even getting to full supply it's not
only likely that bitcoin will not
decrease in value long term
but also that it will actually increase
in value
so it seems like a pretty safe bet
against inflating currencies
which brings me to the comparison with
gold
bitcoin is often compared to gold as
they are both finite resources
which have been consistently
appreciating in comparison
to most worldwide currencies this is of
course unless we eventually get into
asteroid mining
and it makes economical sense to bring
back gold as well as other precious
metals
to earth but as of right now both gold
and bitcoin have limited supply however
one major difference between the two is
how valuable they each are
as of august 2020 bitcoin boasted a
market cap
of 227 billion dollars meaning that the
total value
of all bitcoins in the world stands at
227 billion
that's no scoffable amount but gold
stands at a whopping
nine trillion dollars which indicates
that gold's market cap
is about 40 times higher than that of
bitcoin
if bitcoin was valued like gold then
each bitcoin would actually be valued
at a massive 500 000
and some economists predict that this is
exactly what will happen
by 2030. so definitely something to keep
an eye on
but at the same time one major
difference between the two
is their volatility we have seen bitcoin
swing as much as
eighty percent within just a couple of
months or even weeks
meanwhile gold is quite stable anyways
at the end of the day can bitcoin
actually replace
the major world currencies well
personally
i think the answer is that bitcoin or
some other cryptocurrency
will eventually replace world currencies
and the real question
is within what time frame in order for
bitcoin to be adopted as a national
currency
within any country it has to first hit
three key measures
the first of which being a practical
medium of exchange
bitcoin is really convenient and easy to
complete transactions with
however the vast vast majority of
individuals
and companies do not yet use bitcoin
at the start of 2020 there were only 51
to 52 million cryptocurrency traders
worldwide
so not even one percent of the world
population
on the bright side 2019 did see a 41
increase in bitcoin users if this growth
is able to sustain
throughout the 2020s we would actually
see about 1.5 billion users
by 2030. now of course that is very
optimistic
but given the graphs that bitcoin has
produced in the past
it wouldn't be that surprising assuming
that they are able to reach 1 billion
users by 2030
we may see bitcoin become a popular and
practical currency
throughout the 2030s and 2040s but again
that's on the optimistic side aside from
being generally accepted
and in use bitcoin will have to become
much less volatile
fortunately this goes hand in hand with
the usage of bitcoin
as more individuals hold their money in
bitcoin
and use bitcoins for transactions on a
regular basis
we'll see the elasticity of bitcoin
significantly decline
this is critical for the adoption of
bitcoin as
this is required for prices to remain at
least somewhat stable
otherwise we would see the price of milk
and eggs double or
half over the weekend and finally the
last major function that bitcoin would
have to serve
is being a reliable unit of account this
goes along with the stability of bitcoin
but is more concerned with profits
losses
liabilities and assets here's the thing
sure paying double prices for eggs and
milk may be annoying
however this gets exponentially worse
when you're dealing with big money
for instance let's say you buy a house
for 10 bitcoins
you put two bitcoin down and take a
bitcoin loan
now let's say over the next few years
the value of bitcoin
has in such a scenario what happens to
the price
of your house would your house now be
worth 20 bitcoin
as your house didn't lose any value but
then how much do you owe the bank now
it wouldn't be fair to just pay them
back 8 bitcoins
as they essentially loaned you 16
bitcoins
considering the risks of loaning
interest rates will likely be sky high
and such conundrums will be very
frequent if bitcoin
isn't a reliable unit of account some
other examples
are how much would you get paid each
month and how would stocks be valued
now of course this is the same case with
regular currencies
as well however regular currencies
generally depreciate in a predictable
and reliable manner thus taking up most
of the guesswork
in the end bitcoin needs to become much
more frequently used
and much more stable as a currency
before it can even be considered
as a viable national currency this
coupled with the fact that the
government usually lacks behind
anyways the road for bitcoin being
adopted as national currencies
is many decades out but it will
eventually happen
in my opinion in the meantime it may
very well continue to be a strong
long-term investment do you guys think
cryptocurrency
is the future comment that down below
also
drop a like if you guys appreciate the
depth of this analysis
and check out our community discord to
suggest future video ideas
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one